go to Eric who is calling in from San
Antonio Texas Eric you're on the Dave
Ramsey show hi guys thanks for taking my
call
sure um a different turn from a
deployment earlier this month and Sunday
was revealed to me that my wife has
accumulated sixty-two thousand dollars
in consumer debt over the last eight to
ten months without my knowledge
Wow all the basically the she had we had
student debt and the small car debt
before I left but in our monthly budget
that we've been working that had shown
that had been getting paid those student
loans are in deferment
and so some Sunday I've gotten the
budget all done and we think we're all
done adding up the damage and we'll be
about a thousand dollars over what we
bring in paying the minimums every month
so we've already done this I've come out
of the paid off about sixty thousand
dollars with the consumer debt about
five years ago she sent me her cards all
cut up while I was again
away for the military and you know with
a note let's do this I'm with you and
yeah Eric first first opinion yeah at
first of all I want to thank you for
your service my friend thank you for
doing what you do to protect our
freedoms
you have to feel devastated to have come
back haven't been away to find out this
kind of surprise what did what did she
buy what is she buying
there's nothing it's it's thirty thirty
transactions tam is on in a couple days
there's if you're right what did she buy
if there was something good for me then
I'd be so much happier but it's not it's
just junk and then it's it's a
consolidating companies one of these
places is a thirty four percent okay and
so she was charging these things from
ephraim from online shopping to our
credit card yeah my favorite one is the
banana car the banana republic
but yeah just uh fifteen fifteen
retailers and other ones are just loans
to pay off credit cards personal loans
Eric when she told you this how did you
feel I was well you know that that's
what happens let's do this one more time
and then the sixteen thousand dollars
turned into if we're now at 60 mm so
alright um that's that's my wife and we
all mess up and you know I look to the
is a big forgiver and I want to be like
him unless I want to be like a the king
that my king is to me and yes sir how
many years have you all been married 15
15 years you got kids
yeah we have a 15 year old daughter 15
year old daughter and so as you look at
this I want to dig in because first and
foremost you've got to know how much it
is you know you said it started out at
16 and now it's at 62 if I'm you I'm
gonna pull the three credit reports
TransUnion Experian and Equifax so you
can see and understand exactly what it
is you're dealing with you know cutting
up the cards isn't enough we got to get
on the phone and shut them down people
do that a lot they'll cut up the card
but they can call and get a replacement
card you know right now she's got an
illness and this illness was called
shopping and I don't know if she is
medicating because you were away or it's
something that she can't control but you
all together are gonna have to hit this
thing head-on because this is not okay
this is one of those things that you
start to look at this you got to
understand if we don't make some changes
that not only will your 15 year old
daughter not be able to do some things
but I'm worried about you all so are you
going to be able to live the life you
want to live in retirement are you going
to be able to chase your dreams and so
sitting down together I'm going to tell
you what I would do I'm going to
encourage you all to go to marriage
counseling you need to go talk to your
pastor if you're plugged into a church
but you need to talk to a marriage
counselor together sit down look at this
and let's address it and really try to
figure out how to get her some help now
on the tactical side of you having a
thousand dollars over what you all are
bringing in
here's what you're going to have to do
we're going to have to contact those
creditors have her be on the phone and
you're there and we're talking to them
and you're going to let them know what
you can afford to pay you see the
minimum payment might be $200 a month
but maybe all you can afford to send is
20 and when you call those creditors
remember this my friend you're not
calling to ask for permission you're
calling to give them information and so
there's something in your spirit that
needs to understand that don't expect
them to say oh that's great Eric we're
okay with that they're not they're not
going to be happy about it but here's
the deal
this is about survival right and then I
want you to look from some of those
things she bought can you sell them
right can we have a yard sale if she
needs to take on a job if she's not
already working and if she is she needs
a second job and maybe even a third one
because this has to get rectified and
it's not okay we're not going to turn an
eye to this I love the fact Eric that
you're being nothing but a man because
you're saying we all make mistakes and
you're absolutely right
but this is one that she's continued to
have and so what we have to do is put
some safeguards in place so it's not
repeated yeah great advice there and
this is just something you're going to
have to really stay the course on Eric
this is not easy the marriage part is
huge has Trust broken here they've got
to get this solved they really do and I
think looking at this you know with him
being deployed you know it's real easy
for people to look for vices right and
so looking at this and understanding
he's putting his life on the line that's
right to protect our freedoms here and
to come back and get blindsided with
this it's not okay but like he's like he
said Ken they'd fixed it before and they
can do it again that's what I want them
to go further faster being smarter
that's right hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income a five hundred
thousand dollar Endicott
you